hey 42 here
it was a normal day on the planet
alderaan when as if from nowhere a
moonlike blob appeared in the sky
not that many of the planet's two
billion inhabitants actually noticed
the unidentified object was tiny
so only people who happened to be
looking in exactly the right spot when
it appeared
would have had any chance of seeing it
to those lucky few i can only assume the
sudden appearance of a brand new mini
moon in the sky was quite an exciting
even awe-inspiring event
but that excitement didn't last very
long
because all of a sudden the object began
to glow
seconds later alderaan exploded with a
blinding green light that seemed to
devour the entire sky as a blast of pure
heat vaporized the air and boils the
oceans
in a matter of seconds
it was over
the beautiful mountain planet of
alderaan was gone
and everyone who'd been unfortunate
enough to live there
at the time
was dead
okay so for all you non-star wars geeks
out there what i just described was the
laser-based destruction of the planet
alderaan by the empire's iconic doomsday
device the death star
it's a seminal scene in the first star
wars film and arguably one of the most
famous moments in all of cinema
and it got me thinking is a
planet-killing weapon like the death
star actually a physical possibility and
if it is
could i build one
i mean could we that is humans build one
sorry always wanted to be a super
villain when i was growing up
[Music]
speaking of being an evil genius i'm a
huge fan of stellaris a grand strategy
space exploration game where you can
really become the evil intergalactic
dictator you've always dreamt of
becoming or if you'd prefer you can
become a nature loving species of
anthropoids oh and did i mention yes you
can destroy a planet in stellaris
nice
actually stellaris offers multiple ways
to destroy a planet you can research and
build a colossal ship there are three
classes of colossal ship the colossus
the juggernaut and the star eater each
one can destroy a planet after you equip
it with the celestial body eradicating
weapon of your choosing would you prefer
to use a global pacifier to destroy a
planet
or the world cracker
my money's on the latter furthermore if
you build the star eater colossus you
can equip it with the star cracker
weapon and devour entire stars you can
have a go at destroying planets for free
this weekend by trying stellaris using
the link in the description don't miss
out thanks to stellaris for sponsoring
this video
the first thing i want to point out here
and forgive me for stating the obvious
is that destroying a planet of roughly
the size and composition of earth is
quite a hard thing to do
you may have heard a rumor that if we
were to detonate all the nuclear weapons
on earth at the same time the planet
would explode but that couldn't be
further from the truth
on a planetary scale we humans and our
grand schemes
are practically irrelevant you'll often
hear people talking about how we're
killing the planet through things like
climate change and mass deforestation
but we really aren't like not even a
tiny bit
what we're actually doing is making our
planet significantly less livable for
ourselves and every other living thing
that's found here as for the planet
itself
seriously it couldn't give any less of a
earth is a six septillion kilogram
wrecking ball made of rock and iron
six
septillion
that's a six with 24 zeros after it in
the past 600 million years alone it
survived impacts from at least 60
asteroids with a diameter of five or
more kilometers one of the largest of
those struck earth 66 million years ago
and according to some estimates it might
have been close to 100 kilometers across
it's smashed into our planet with the
explosive power of 10 billion nuclear
weapons wiping out 75 of life including
all non-avian dinosaurs and leaving
behind a 180 kilometer wide crater on a
human scale it was an unimaginably
devastating event
a genuine apocalypse but the planet as a
whole hardly even noticed
what i'm trying to say is that
in technical terms planet earth is one
chunky boy
destroying it or a planet like it would
require a weapon trillions of times more
powerful than anything in existence
today as for what that weapon might look
like well it turns out something like
the death star might actually be a
pretty good place to start when i say
the word laser there's a fair chance
your mind clunges up images if those
little laser pointers fancy pens
business types like to use in
presentations
but even today military-grade laser
technology is already pretty frightening
stuff with the power to target and
destroy aircraft and even satellites
mid-flight so all we'd need to do to
make a weapon of death star proportions
is scale things up a bit well i say a
bit to completely destroy something as
big as a planet we need to develop a
laser with around a billion trillion
times more power than the lasers we have
today and even if we were actually able
to do it
such great power would inevitably come
with great economic responsibilities
back in 2012 some bright sparks set up a
petition to the us government in an
attempt to secure funding for the
construction of an actual death star
citing the very reasonable benefits of a
boost to national security and the
creation of millions of jobs
the petition gained almost 35 000
signatures and remarkably enough the
white house actually responded
sadly that response was a hard no due to
an estimated total build cost of about
850 quadrillion dollars
about 13 000 times the gdp of every
country on earth put together at the
time
there would also be plenty of
engineering problems to overcome too
no lazing material known to man would be
able to withstand the incredible heat of
such a device
and whatever humanity's death star
itself was actually made out of would
melt like an easter egg in a blast
furnace as soon as it was turned on
hey maybe one day it'll be possible and
like in stellaris we'll see world
cracking glazes but realistically we're
talking hundreds or more likely
thousands of years in humanity's future
luckily there's more than one way to
skin a cat
and indeed destroy a planet
and at least one of those ways employs a
technology or should i say substance
that we've already been producing
for a good 70 years or so
antimatter
think of antimatter as being a bit like
regular mata's evil twin a material
composed of anti-particles with
properties that are the exact opposite
of regular matter
antimatter is fascinating stuff that
deserves an entire video on its own but
for the purposes of this one all we need
to know is that when antimatter and
regular mata meet they annihilate each
other releasing vast amounts of energy
so much energy that a single gram of
antimatter could create an explosion
comparable in size to that of a nuclear
bomb
the very fact that it instantly blows up
when it comes into contact with regular
matter which as you probably noticed is
absolutely bloody everywhere
makes antimatter rather difficult to
handle
it can't be stored in any kind of
conventional
based containers for obvious reasons
instead needing to be held suspended
within powerful magnetic fields and it
turns out that isn't even the biggest
issue we'd have to overcome to build a
viable anti-matter bomb as we've already
established earth is a chunky boy and so
we'd still need a few trillion tons of
antimatter to destroy it
but making antimatter is tricky
to do so you need amongst other things a
powerful particle accelerator like the
large hadron collider at cern in
switzerland but even if you were to run
that formidable machine non-stop as a
dedicated anti-matter factory
it would still only produce about a
billionth of a gram of antimatter
per year
meaning the entire lifespan of the
universe
might not provide us with enough time to
make an antimatter based doomsday device
capable of chunking a planet even if it
did the total cost of the project would
make building a death star
look like a bargain
estimates vary but as of today creating
a gram of antimatter costs about 63
trillion dollars
just as was the case with lasers the
problem here is one of scale
one shutting something as big as a
planet requires us to push the kind of
destructive technologies we currently
know about to almost unimaginable limits
but then
maybe we've been looking at this problem
from the wrong perspective
what if instead of building one giant
ending weapon
we just make a crap ton of little ones
well not weapons exactly more like
weaponized self-replicating robots
it's an idea that's being explored by
such scientific heavyweights as freeman
dyson and john von neumann and it's both
incredibly simple and absolutely
ingenious
imagine you designed a robot of roughly
the same combination of materials that
your target planet is made out of
now imagine that robot had the
capability both to harvest those
materials
and use them to create an exact copy of
itself theory all you'd have to do is
build and activate a single one of those
robots to destroy an entire planet let
it loose and as per its programming the
robot would head out into the world
looking for a likely spot
then start to dig once it had collected
all the raw materials necessary it would
pause to build a clone of itself
once complete both the clone and its
parent would move on harvesting more raw
materials and turning them into new
generations of clones intuitively you
might assume it would take forever to
destroy a planet this way but the number
of clones would double with every
generation
meaning the total population will grow
exponentially after just 40 generations
more than a trillion self-replicating
robots would be busy taking your planet
apart piece by piece
all this talk of self-replicating robots
reminds me of the grey tempest special
event in stellaris i fondly remember the
first time i encountered it in game
after passing through a mysterious warp
gate i discovered in a far-off star
system it really freaked me out and
before i knew it my homeworld was being
bombarded by alien nanites slowly
devouring my population it might sound
like a fairly outlandish concept
but think about it
what i've just described an autonomous
machine that harvests raw materials from
its environment in order to make copies
of itself isn't that just an accurate
description
of a human being or any other animal for
that matter there would still be some
fairly major challenges to overcome
along the way like exactly how these
machines would handle temperatures of
more than 5000 degrees celsius in the
planet's core for example but in many
ways self-replicating robots might be
the most feasible way for humans to
destroy a planet
partly because they completely
circumvent the whole scale issue we see
with more conventional weapons
with all this talk of how we could
harness human technology to build the
most destructive weapons in existence
it's easy to forget that there are
already untold trillions of super
weapons
basically just lying around all over the
place throughout the entire universe we
don't tend to think of them that way of
course but there's a good chance nothing
human-made will ever rival the sheer
might and majesty of your average
run-of-the-mill star or world-ending
terror of a bog-standard black hole
so rather than spending our time
dreaming up inventive ways to speed up
anti-matter production or dynamics our
lasers
we might be better off just shooting
whatever it is we want to destroy
at the nearest star or black hole
either of which will be capable of
swallowing a planet the size of earth as
easily as you might eat and after dinner
mint
moving something as big as a planet is
of course a mammoth task that presents a
fair few scale problems all of its own
but for now it might prove to be rather
easier than blowing one up entirely
thanks for watching